Ross, there is one thing a lot of people can get behind,
which is a good old-fashioned Netflix binge.
(Ross mmhmms)
And there's so many shows out there,
but a lot of people are returning to "The Gilmore Girls."
Well, and I mean, it ran for seven seasons,
and then it had like an ender thing, and it came back,
and it's a relationship between a mother and a daughter.
I've got plenty of baggage in that department.
And now a film and TV site called ScreenRant,
says the show may be 20 years old,
but it's still full of parenting wisdom.
Okay, this is kind of a debate though.
And here to dig into it with us is psychologist,
parenting expert, friend of mine, and friend of the show,
oh, and a "Gilmore Girls" diehard, Aliza Pressman.
Dr. Aliza Pressman.
Hi Dr. Aliza, hi.
Hi.
Okay, what do you feel about "Gilmore Girls,"
and mothers and daughters watching it?
"Gilmore Girls" is a great opportunity
to bond with your kid, like any show where you can connect,
because it's a great story, and it's cozy, and delicious.
And for some younger kids, not too young,
but if you're watching it with your younger child,
do you have lots of stories that you can explain.
The good stuff is the relationship,
the beautiful relationship and connection
between Lorelei and her daughter, Rory.
the stuff that's a little wonky,
but it's also great for talking through
is that that's a best friendship,
and sometimes that's kind of missing some boundaries,
'cause you never wanna feel like you,
your kid has to take care of your emotional needs,
or feels like they're on equal footing with you.
And you know, without them, you might fall.
But then there's also these other relationships,
like her mother, the main, the mother's mother,
didn't raise her kid to be who she was.
And so, Lorelei ran away from her,
and it estranged her from her daughter.
And that's a great lesson too.
Like, don't try to raise a different kid,
raise the kid you have, so that you can stay connected.
Do you think it's just this show that's so interesting?
Because I feel like it's been the first time
we saw this kind of relationship
between a mother and daughter,
like, very much the BFF-
On television.
On television, well, yeah.
Do we see it another places too?
Hello. (audience laughs)
Hello.
But we saw it on television,
and they had a healthy relationship.
Do you really think there's things we can learn?
Like bits of wisdom that they revealed to us?
Yeah, I mean, they bond and connect over the things
they mutually like share,
like their love of bingeing television shows,
and watch, they couldn't binge then,
but they could watch movies together,
and order lots of food.
And just like they have these moments of bonding,
even though they're very different.
And the mother never tries to turn her daughter
into someone she's not, even though her daughter
is totally the opposite of her,
and maybe somebody she might've even
made fun of when she was younger
That journey from mother and daughter being friends,
I don't advocate.
I, it makes me nervous from my own personal life experience.
But what is the rule?
Like, what is too friendy-friendy for mom and daughter?
What are the bumper rails?
Because I've only got my own baggage to like recall on,
what is safe mother-daughter behavior?
I think, ask yourself these two questions.
Are my emotional needs being met by my child,
or someone else?
If you answer by your child, it's just pay attention,
boundaries are getting crossed.
And the second thing to ask yourself
is does my child imagine that
they are the sole caretaker of my emotions?
Do they feel responsible for me?
If they understand you have you,
you know how to take care of yourself,
you're gonna take care of them,
and you're gonna teach them to take care of themselves,
but they never have to worry about taking care of you.
I mean, until you're really old.
Then you've got it, you're good.
The issue is, do they feel like they have to take care
of both themselves and you?
And are you not able to take care of them?
(mmhmms) That could be a burden.
Okay, how damaging is it for the child
if they see you cry?
'Cause I'm not gonna lie, I've broken down numerous times
in the last year because of the pandemic.
And we're stuck at home together and I'm drowning.
Well, that's different.
That's, you know, you can cry in front of your kids,
but just let them know, hey, this is how I'm coping.
I'm getting my feelings out,
but I know how to take care of myself in this moment.
And in this moment, I'm feeling sad.
That doesn't mean they need to take care of you,
or they're scarred.
That means they know, hey, this is one of the feelings
my mom is having, and in this household,
we learned that all feelings are welcome.
They're around, and they're not something to be afraid of.
Okay, I like, now that I've got you, I'm so sorry.
I don't even know what subject we're on, I'm so greedy.
I just wish I could move in with you and live with you,
And have you tell me every little thing
I'm supposed to do when I'm supposed to do it,
'cause everything you say makes so much sense,
And also we're all, and I'm gonna quote you on this,
we're all just doing our best,
and you have to give yourself grace,
because that's part of this too.
And our kids learn that, you know?
When we blow it, we don't beat ourselves up.
Well, maybe instead of Drew moving in with you,
could you just come back and visit us again?
(audience laughs)
(laughs) That feels balanced.
Yeah, that's good, yeah, okay, good.
We found the pretty little middle.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, and for anyone, I just remembered,
we started talking about "Gilmore Girls."
Yeah. (laughs)
So.
We got it.
Yep, all right.
Thank you, Dr. Aliza.
We'll have another question for you ASAP.
(warm rock music)
♪ Oh-oh (Oh-oh) ♪